What really launched my serious research
into network effects on the economics of
network effects with some of the work
that I was doing in human capital and
the notion that innovation isn't just a
transaction.
Innovation is an investment in the human
capital and capabilities and
competencies and creativity of your
customer's network.
Effects are basically how customers or
users create value for each other.
It's basically an external to the
individual user.
So an example of a network effect would
be if you and I had a phone that would
be great for you and I,
but in network effect is the more people
who use phones,
the more valuable the phone network
becomes,
the more valuable each other become
because we can call more people and more
people can call us and heck,
they may even be the opportunity to do a
conference call,
which is another form of network effect.
So network effects are basically a way
that the more people participate in
using a product or service,
the more valuable it becomes.
There's no such thing anymore as a non
networked organization.
Now,
admittedly,
some networks are better than others,
but we can absolutely make the case that
one of the fundamental transformations
over the last 50 years is the network
effication of large organizations and
small organizations,
not just in OACD countries,
but all over the world network
suffocation has taken over the world.
It's how do you get value from these
networks?
There's a wonderful line from the,
the first industrial sociologist,
a Frenchman by the name of Frederick Law
play.
He was the superintendent of a cold.
The minds and his phrase was the most
important product of the mine is the
minor.
It's not the coal,
it's not the metal,
it's not the 10 it's the human capital
that allows you to extract the value
from the mind.
So that's update this to the 21st
century.
The most important product of the
network is the networker,
not the bits,
not the bites,
not the bandwidth,
not the data.
It's the people.
And in an Internet of things age,
the things,
the machines,
the devices on the network,
if we can make networkers more valuable,
we make our networks more valuable.
And that is indeed the recipe for an
Amazon,
for a google,
for a Yelp,
for a Linkedin,
for an at t,
and t for Netflix.
What does Google do to make customers
better?
It,
it gives them the ability to search and
iterate on those searches.
And what does Google do?
It converts those clicks into more
efficient search.
That's the essence of a web 2.0 network
effects company.
The same holds for the Amazon
recommendation engine or for Netflix.
So what you're doing is you're making it
in.
You're not just giving customers what
they want,
you're investing in improving their
capabilities.
What was another way that Google did
that Google gave you for free gmail
email,
which enables it to learn more about
your social network,
what you're interested in communicating
about,
et cetera.
Same thing with linkedin.
So the whole notion,
that's why linkedin bought a company
like Linda.
So not just to improve people's resume,
but to improve people's skills.
So the,
the notion of a network effect here is
as we give our customers the ability to
do more for themselves,
they can do more with us and on our
network.
So in the early days of the telephone,
all you could do was talk to someone,
then you could do a facts,
then you could do a conference call.
Then there were these things called
modems that allowed you to send email.
You are increasing the capability of the
customer,
allowed you to get more value from the
network.
And indeed customers want it to do so
much.
You had to do what you had to redesign
the architectures and the capabilities
of the network.
So you have an iterative network
development process here as customer
capabilities and capacities increase,
you have to change the capabilities and
capacities of the network and vice
versa.